c'est ce plaisir aujourd'hui on se
trompe ce royaume de fusion mais aussi
un dlc qui vient de sortir qui s'appelle
à aussonne la main se souvient plus à me
semble le même match pardon je vois une
licorne en font donc sans que ça me
plait un chat qui possède un des gueules
sur une licorne tatoué si ça c'est pas
bad as me est sage ou comment comme une
moto où ça galope mais non mélo osé
faire ça va plus vite
allez on y va jeunes licorne ont eu
envie ça se déplace droit comme une moto
c'est hyper étrange quoi merde [ __ ]
crache du feu même oh mon dieu ça va
trop c'est quoi ce bordel
jme téléporte en fait tagada je fais un
backflip le bon chat bien décédé tôt ça
joue en plastique la halle basilique en
allemagne mais pourquoi ils crachent du
feu bordel je peux faire des willy ou
pas tant des eaux
aïe la paix mais il a passé les cordes
ah oui oui comme tu veux voilà ce qui se
passe quand tu amènes de la drogue dans
un studio de développement de jeux ça
donne ça rôlistes on la ramène à la vie
les guerriers shia antique avec le petit
bruit de mort c'était sympa ça au lac
étals señorita ce jeu vient vous sauver
maintenant je sais ça suffit à me battre
et des animaux comme ça là oh la la
c'est quoi ça vaut bien
nickel dimanche on cherche les chalands
pic à bonjour la colonne verte et la
thorn o
le pack oh là là mais ce talent allez on
y va on y va aller à léo c'est un
chantier que ça mon dieu pourquoi nous
en voyeur c'est sa voix la hâte en mai
mais je dois faire du doigt faire du
cirque
[Musique]
mais non à la nuque
au revoir licorne cheveux je suis si
bien sans toi elle me manque déjà aux
mondiaux chez antik vert il ne manque
plus que le dernier c'est le guerrier on
a eu le mage larcher manque plus que le
terrain soit dans un rpg yalaoui âgées
reconnu le lieu le mans legend erne de
l'ancien shah c'est trop tôt tu vois ses
déchirures dans l'espace-temps fonce
dedans
moi j'adore cette logique tu vois cette
autoroute traverse la ola là-haut [ __ ]
alors et c'est le chaos total quoi y'a
la batmobile juste derrière laquelle
assista au bon dieu elle va tomber à
tout fait péter le tuyau attend quoi ça
à tout schéma que quoi jusqu'à preuve du
contraire les poils un oui je sais je
sais je sais je mais qu'on est en train
de voler dans l'espace sur des morceaux
de pierre il demandait crockett qui dit
petite planète dit souvent faible
gravité
c'est vrai d'ailleurs ça me rappelle un
proverbe français qui dit petit
reprendre le jeu j'ai lancé ce père
désastre j'aime te faire griller il ya
là les cordes bien là je t'aime
nous sommes assez pas les quand jose un
caillou les cordes c'était une embuscade
d'ailleurs petite info c'est djabou qui
a fait le doublage du jeu voilà c'est
totalement faux mondiaux elle tremble
elle a froid est là devant moi
elle crache du feu pour se réchauffer à
la voix je suis la licorne
elle veut me dégager cébrades [ __ ]
perturbations céleste avec beats croque
voilà en guest
l'escroc le slide ducup allée licorne
allez allez tu y vas tu m'as info mais
l'air las quand même tu vois pas de
cheveux énervé put avance avant sinon tu
sait ce qui nous attend
c'est bien beau tout ça mais j'ai pas vu
brûler bazire regardes tu vois comment
on fait peur bras la question à faire je
crois que je brûle je brûle or moi je
brûle plus il a tenté l'attentât un
grade mais non sa part sur un graffiti
mondiaux et voilà c'est la fin du film
soto bientôt pour mad max le combat de
boss venir le coupable
est ce qu'il y aura là unicorn mk3 c'est
ça qu'on se demande aux siens de près et
c'est un chaud lapin très bien c'est un
show chat et ça c'est un show bid ya pas
de titan n'y a pas de bosse ya pas hugo
hugo boss à moi j'en ai marre
voilà je vais faire une pétition pour
que squeeze arrête de vidéos vont te le
voilà le moscato qu'il faut que je fasse
du tombe dessus
oh oui oh non adam il faut que je reste
du su agen bat bien mais là vraiment ça
passe sur un rpg world of rivals
on est bien là on est bien voilà écoute
moi bien petit pingouin obèses va
arrêter a assez tendue à wall-e corde
ok j'ai tenté un 8c pourra faire une
arrivée stylet mais non
et sinon la licorne avec rage des
flammes et c'est fini un voile a passé
une fin alternative non oui oui les 2 cv
regardez-moi saint gobain cela dans
l'espace ok donc on a fini à houssen
adventure il ya un autre truc red wings
devaient sol stars et moi je dis des
courses difficiles là ya pas d course
vraiment dit ah voilà tu fais extrême à
howie alors pour la paix oui oh regardez
comment vérité qu au fait des ridicules
ou bien mais c'est pas possible là je ne
peux pas faire une conséquence très avec
la donne qu'un regard des voilages et on
gazon bonjour un aléa les la petite
banque et l on y va en vivant mais en
fait tout tout devient une course
extrême quand tu avec cette photo ça qui
est dingue aillent là on est bien là on
est bien regarder cette lancée cette
lancée le têt dans le tuyau lytvyn
violence facepalm au oui je m'en fous
j'adore ce poteau je travaille un petit
peu les cuisses là ça fait du bien à
elle et à bientôt
j'ai un beau cul mais j'aurais aimé
finir la course quand même un dieu oh
mon dieu oh mon dieu de cette fournée
bon cette fois des mots posés avec les
poteaux soit padeg si jacuzzi au calme
que goethe abandonnerai jamais petit
bateau vient avec moi bien
eh ben pour la peine on va faire
puissance cuche sait pas ce que c'est
mais ça me tente
à combien deux faces du cube survivra tu
attends mais déjà allez on y va on y va
on y va
allez allez pousser style et sa non non
j'aime pas les trous week-end
ouais moi j'aime bien retourner en avant
mais je pensais que le cube il allait se
remettre dans l'autre sens retenu l'un
vraiment je suis déçu que déception
allez allez troisième phase est parti
s'il vous plaît voilà qui nous fait pas
peur mais je te baise départ pour la ds
à mon dieu avec de la lawe partout alors
là dans lequel j'aime bien mais je suis
plutôt lapin donc je vais prendre le
temps j'avais oublié celui-là est tout
bonnement oublié en fait
allez allez allez tu pédales tu pédales
c'est bien au vélo en fait en vrai c'est
trop bien regarder il peut monter des
trucs tout également montée j'avais fait
à part les bons jours ah ça c'est ça ça
fait exprès voilà comme ça un petit
moment tranquille en intimité
j'attends du début au maire juif tempête
touche aux noms courts circuits à temps
à la lecture rouge sur un clavier c'est
ça tu roules dans le pc carrément
actuellement on est à côté d'un intel i5
un jeu reconnaît aaa mais non mais quel
con mais [ __ ] on dirait un enfant de 8
ans quand je rage mais c'est super dur
ça soit que ces mecs de rennes ii x4
festive au fait s'il habite difficulté
moyen même au coût moyen côté
développeur du jeu depuis cinq ans way
juste ici la carte graphique c'est donc
une nvidia gt étant mais je vais passer
la vidéo j'étais je vous le dis on
allait
et non il te plait [ __ ] je vais
prendre une mda nvidia
allez je sais qu'on peut le faire tu
sais aussi qu'on peut le faire mais on
s'entend si bien tous les deux on adore
lancé battlefield on adore lancer
vraiment les jeux bien comment tu sais
que je demande un peu beaucoup de voix
quand je pousse ses performances au max
même mais bon je sais c'est affectif ou
allez monsieur g force on y va monsieur
j'ai fort tiens ça me touche quoi
non même pas aller pourquoi pourquoi ce
bouton existe voilà il fait recommencer
toute la course
et voilà j'en suis déjà fin de cette
vidéo sur dlc de transfusion l on peut
quand même monté de nikon avec un chat
je vais vous dire eh ben je vais rien
vous dire j'espère qu'elle n'a plus ses
cannes et se répète mais la vidéo comme
d'habitude et on se retrouve très
bientôt dans une nouvelle attention
merci d'avoir regardé le show tout le
monde pis
[Musique]